[Laughter]
so who's pushing me are you pushing me
or is brian pushing me christian i'll
push you okay really okay you're first
and then brian next
great to go down there because they have
all that wonderful food that's open now
and kirsten all just talks about the
tater tots tots potato supposedly the
best
live look outside right now great sunset
shot and our latest flow facts you guys
ready for this
cotton candy was invented by a dentist
no
really that first cotton candy machine
was called the
fairy floss that was the name of it wow
koalas have fingerprints true story
which is why i want a koala now
i want one too
they're too cute
all right live look outside right now
how about those numbers at this hour not
bad at all very comfortable 71 degrees
for centennial hill 67 for someone 73
were for downtown north las vegas the
east side always warmer there because
you're lower in elevation 78 for you
sunrise manor green valley 75 henderson
72 rhodes ranch 74 southern highlands 67
degrees outside of town 74 for indian
springs 73 for mesquite 79 currently for
lofland 80 still out in death valley at
this hour radar network i have all the
sweeps going around trying to find some
precip not no showers nothing at all
right now even though storms up in the
pacific northwest are now finally coming
to an end for now clear skies that front
has passed through there it is now we've
got those clear skies but looking at
more clouds coming in off the coast like
that and we'll see those clouds increase
later on tonight in the meantime your
winds stay light for the most part for
the valley but i think the northern
neighborhoods will still get some of
that breeze in fact you can see here in
our wind cast the area neighborhoods
when you see the double digit wind
speeds right there that's because we'll
get some of those north breezes to kick
in tomorrow in the afternoon and they'll
be around also for thursday but really
focusing their attention again the
colorado valley laughlin bullhead seeing
the lake those of you could still see
some pretty good gusts tomorrow and
especially on thursday your forecast
overnight 52 degrees more clouds and a
chilly start tomorrow we're going to
bring back tornado ted
57 degrees and cool
at 1p
brian ryan likes to mention that he
likes to say you are your hands are not
that big they really are not
they really are not that big that is
true 63 degrees
super nice for tomorrow by the afternoon
temperatures will be nice and comfy
actually we should be in the
high 60s by the afternoon and then 63
degrees by the time we get to 6 p.m
eight day forecast does show
temperatures hovering right around 70
degrees again there are your home games
the knights the raiders unlv the rebels
and also we'll be looking at a mix of
sun and clouds all week into next week
as well not a bad forecast at all that's
your most accurate forecast here on
eight news now guys over to you